hey everyone its warrant I've been
getting a lot of questions about the
supposed Avengers endgame footage that
is supposed to be shown during the
Superbowl tomorrow so here's a quick
video on all of the questions that I've
gotten and everything you need to know
about the Super Bowl and the possible
Avengers in-game footage we're supposed
to see tomorrow
the main question that I've been getting
is what time is the Super Bowl ah and
where can I watch it the Super Bowl
starts at 6:30 p.m. Eastern Time in the
United States so you can go to google
and type that in and convert it to
whatever time zone you're in and you can
watch the Super Bowl on CBS or you can
stream it for free online at CBS
sports.com it'll also be on the CBS
sports app as well the next question
that I've been getting asked a lot is is
the second Avengers in-game trailer
confirmed for the Super Bowl and just to
be clear this is not the second trailer
for Avengers in game the first one that
we got was in fact a teaser trailer but
this next one is not a full trailer it's
most likely just a 30-second TV spot
with a little bit of new footage Super
Bowl commercials are extremely expensive
they cost millions and millions and
millions of dollars so just like they
did for Avengers infinity war this one
should only be about 30 seconds long and
it's not confirmed Marvel won't confirm
it this is just like The Avengers
in-game teaser trailer Marvel will not
confirm that there's going to be a TV
spot at the Super Bowl
no one from Marvel confirmed that the
Avengers endgame teaser trailer was
going to come out when it did but people
who had insider information did confirm
it so this is the same thing people have
heard that it's going to come out during
the Superbowl so that's what they're
reporting but Marvel will not confirm
this but as I mentioned in a few videos
Marvel has released new footage of their
upcoming movies that past three
consecutive years guardians of the
galaxy - Captain America Civil War and
last year Avengers infinity war so since
Marvel has done this the past several
years it's expected for them to do the
same thing with Avengers in game I've
heard reports that there is supposed to
be a TV spot during the Superbowl
tomorrow but Marvel will not confirm
anything the same thing happened for
Avengers infinity war last year there
were reports that we were going to see
footage but Marvel never said anything
it has been confirmed however that
Disney has bought several commercial
spots for the Super Bowl possibly for
The Lion King Aladdin
and Marvel and of course Avengers in
game so be sure to watch the Super Bowl
tomorrow there's an extremely high
chance that we'll get footage for
Avengers in game if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on everything Marvel
related and Avengers in game and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]
you